I bump into you here in town Los Angeles
and you were with your family and I I
got the sense that you come from very
nice but maybe a bit of a conservative
family is that right like your mom your
mom's a little bit more straight-laced
yes she's she's very she's very much a
Democrat she hates it when I describe
her as conservative because she's very
much a Democrat but she is incredibly
prudish right and I do like to needle
her a bit now she's loosened up a little
bit and I I do an amongst a number of
things I send her up
obnoxious postcards obnoxious postcards
what do you mean sexy postcards you know
the ones that have like California like
you know the ladies and bikinis in the
80s and it's like come visit California
oh and it's so a bunch of women in
bikini bottom
yeah a bit like the high-waisted ones
because I know that she's friends with
the postman and I know that as he's
putting the postcard into the mailbox I
see my mom and visioning that and I can
feel her getting annoyed and I delight
in these postcards oh they're like
anonymous yeah yeah like having a great
time in California trying to pursue my
dreams
xoxo yeah say hi to Randy or whatever I
think you brought one of the postage you
really sent your mom Kaymer ones but
it's good right yeah that's a good
choice yeah I think you did very well
yeah
twins twins I've got that as a poster
[Applause]
you